The Marvel Cinematic Universe's first post-credits
scene almost looked into the franchise's future…
way into the future.
At the 2019 Saturn Awards, Marvel Studios
head honcho Kevin Feige appeared in a brief
video clip to share an alternate version of
Iron Man's famous stinger with the crowd.
It's probably for the best that they went
with a simplified take, because if they had
used the alternate, Marvel fans' heads would
have exploded.
The clip is part of an apparent treasure drove
of deleted scenes from the MCU that will be
made available on the Infinity Saga box set,
and it features a very different version of
the speech Nick Fury gives to Tony Stark after
surprising the billionaire at his home.
The original post-credits scene of Iron Man
introduced audiences to Fury, and clued them
in that, yes, all these Marvel movies were
going to be connected.
"Mr. Stark, you've become part of a bigger
universe you just don't know it yet."
Marvel comics die-hards went absolutely bananas
over the reveal of Jackson as Fury and the
teased possibility of an Avengers movie but
the alternate version that Feige screened
for fans would have had them freaking out
exponentially harder.
Here's the alternate line of dialogue that
would have changed everything:
"As if gamma accidents, radioactive bug bites,
and assorted mutants weren't enough …"
Wait — what?!
The implication of the existence of Spider-Man
and the X-Men in the MCU's very first film,
no less would have blown fans out of their
seats.
Fury continues ...
"... I have to deal with a spoiled brat who
doesn't play well with others, and who wants
to keep all of his toys to himself."
The "Who the hell are you?"
exchange between Fury and Stark is the same
as in the final version, but there's an additional
exchange that is also new:
"Well, what are we avenging?"
"Whatever the hell we want."
The pre-Sokovia Accords era was such an innocent
time, eh?
But back to the Fury's mind-blowing opening
line.
Remember, at that time, the film rights to
the X-Men were owned by Fox Studios, who had
been busily cranking out successful films
based on these properties for the past eight
years.
The rights to Spider-Man were held by Sony
Pictures, which had fielded an immensely successful
film trilogy based on the wall-crawler, and
was a few years away from rebooting the property.
Of course, the last few years have made this
alternate version of the Iron Man stinger
scene appear downright prophetic.
Following the striking of a shared custody
deal between Sony and Marvel, Spider-Man has
enjoyed a three-year, five-picture run in
the MCU.
Negotiations to re-up that deal have recently
hit an impasse, making the cinematic future
of the character a bit unclear but in 2008,
the idea that Spidey could ever appear in
a film from scrappy upstart Marvel Studios
was downright laughable.
Likewise, the formerly Fox-owned properties
are now free and clear for use in the MCU,
but it took two seismic developments for that
to happen: Marvel Studios and Fox Studios
were both purchased by the same parent company,
the increasingly monolithic Disney.
In 2009, the House of Mouse purchased Marvel
Studios for just over $4 billion dollars,
which turned out to be a pretty sweet deal
for a production house that would eventually
turn the MCU into the highest-grossing film
franchise in history.
Then, earlier this year, Disney acquired the
film and television assets of Fox for an eye-popping
$71.3 billion dollars.
While one of the primary purposes of the acquisition
was to secure Fox's incredibly deep television
library to bolster its upcoming streaming
service Disney+, it goes without saying that
bringing all of those legacy characters home
to Marvel was some pretty fantastic icing
slathered liberally on that cake.
But in 2008, there would have been no reason
to think that the X-Men and the Avengers could
ever play in the same cinematic sandbox.
At any rate, it's fascinating to see what
might have been and even more so to think
what else Feige and company will be dragging
out of their vault to share with us for the
Infinity Saga's box set release.
It has yet to be announced when the collection
will hit store shelves, but we'll be all over
it when it does.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.